we have new information about a
real-life treasure hunt that hooked
people all over the world and if you
were still hoping to find this treasure
it's not really good news for you here's
the back story ten years ago a new
mexico art dealer named forest fan
created a poem with clues to the
location of a hidden treasure
his challenge created a frenzied hunt
for the chess containing well here's why
it's frenzied more than 100 more than a
million dollars worth of valuables a lot
of money there
then announced six months ago that the
treasure had been found here's the news
now we know who found it janet chamleon
reports
with the clue into the mountains north
of santa fe it's believed
tens of thousands have searched the
rockies for forest fence treasure chest
filled with millions in gold and
precious jewels several lost their lives
doing so
in june fence said it had finally been
discovered but that the finder wanted to
remain anonymous
a secret fenn took to his grave when he
died in september at the age of 90.
now the mystery is over after the finder
initially posted anonymously
about his discovery how are you able to
find out who he was
i figured out a way to um flag a typo
inside the story which allows you to get
a little bit of information to send
to the author of the post he's 32 year
old michigan medical student
jack stoof who revealed himself to
author and fellow treasure hunter daniel
barbaresi
who's writing a book about the hunt
chasing the thrill
we had a good relationship for a few
months in that way of going back and
forth about all this stuff about the
treasure
until out of the blue one day he just
said hey i think it's going to come out
you want to know who i am and i said
all right let's talk why stoof revealed
himself a lot less epic than the
adventure that led him to the treasure
fearing a lawsuit would eventually name
him he came forward
in the suit an illinois woman claims stu
found the treasure by hacking
her computer and emails she believed
fenn's chest was in new mexico
stoof told barbarisi he found it in
wyoming after a two-year search
and says he's never met the woman in a
statement to cbs news fenn's family says
we can confirm that jack is the
legitimate finder of the chest that my
granddad hid
and we wish him the best for stoof the
allure wasn't the value but the chance
he says
to live out a teenage fantasy of
treasure hunting
that is one to be the one who cracks
that code the code stoof says he cracked
was written by fen in 2010
when he released a self-published memoir
the thrill of the chase
which included a poem with clues to the
treasure's location
cbs sunday morning's barry peterson
spoke to fenn about the hunt
in 2015. well i made it hard
deliberately
if it was easy anyone could do it
barbarisi says stoof won't reveal
exactly where in wyoming he found the
treasure
even with the best of intentions people
tramping in and out of there is going to
ruin the pristine nature of that place
who has a treasure hunt in 2020
it's it's an anachronism it's a fantasy
it shouldn't exist
the woman following the lawsuit in a
statement to cbs news
calls the statement by the fenn family
more nonsense
and continues to question the legitimacy
of the discovery
on a separate note i have covered
forrest fenn and this story and have met
with him
at his home at least a half a dozen
times over the past several years
and i was among those who questioned
whether he even hid the treasure in the
first place
especially this summer when he announced
there was an anonymous finder
just two months before he passed away
but now we know jack stoof is the finder
and stoof says he has student loans to
pay off
and he will auction off that treasure
anthony oh
there's a lot of money for it yeah
didn't you do it too didn't you
so i was the first person to do a big
old long article back in 2012
and then i went on tv on cnn brook
baldwin thanks for having me i
appreciate that
uh and then it really exploded from
there uh
and you had doubts too though tony no i
always thought that the chess was real
and i think my article helped lend
credibility to like forrest is an
unusual guy and only a very unusual guy
would bury a bunch of treasure and say
so you always thought there was money
that i always thought it was real but
until now i doubted that it had really
been found
because forrest wanted immortality he
was thinking in in millennia terms
and so i had a doubt about something i
couldn't remember timing surprised me